For starting today with something that's sort
of really funny but also sad and really just
a sign of how
disconnected from facts and rationality we
have gotten as a matter of sort of standard
political discourse in the United States.
And I'll explain yesterday they were impeachment
hearings. They were the first hearings in
the judiciary committee. Everything in the
weeks prior was in the house intelligence
committee led by Adam Schiff yesterday, nearly
nine hours of hearings. We were there for
every minute live streaming, uh, nine hours
of hearings overseen in the judiciary committee
by Congressman Jerry Nadler. And they brought
in, Democrats, brought in three well known
legal scholars to lay out the case for why
Donald Trump's actions meet the standard required
for impeachment. Now, this is not anything
about would articles be filed? How would the
trial go? How would senators vote? It's merely
legal experts saying, here's the standard
for impeachment. Here is historical information,
here is legal information, and here is how
Trump's actions fit into that. They were professors
know a Feldman, Pamela Carlin and Michael
Gerhardt who did this.
It was again, nearly nine hours of hearings.
The Republican strategy was mostly talk only
to their witness. They brought one witness,
Republicans did Jonathan Turley, and a focus
merely on how he believes there is no need
to impeach. There was no case for impeachment.
But when Republicans did talk to the three
witnesses called by the democratic majority
in the house of representatives, the strategy
was attack them, attack their credibility,
attack them personally as biased partisan
actors rather than the legal experts that
they are. And one of the funniest such attacks
was from a Congressman named Matt Gates. Now
if you don't know Matt Gates, you're probably
much happier in your life than people who
do know who this guy is because he is such
bottom feeding, you know? Anyway, he is one
of the basis bomb throwers of the, we always
defend Trump movement or camp. He tries to
go after professor Carlin by pointing out
that she made legal political contributions
and he really sounds very dumb doing it. Take
a look at this.
Do you appreciate your testimony, professor
Carlin? You gave 2000 bucks or you gave 1000
bucks to Elizabeth Warren, right? I believe
so. You gave 1200 bucks to Barack Obama. I
have no reason. Question that. And you gave
2000 bucks to Hillary Clinton. That's correct.
That's so much more for Hillary than the other
two because I've been giving a lot of money
to charity recently because of all of the
poor people in the United States. The only,
those aren't the only folks that you've been
given to.
There's lots of poor people in the U S I found
a professor, Carlin quick-witted and impressive
and formidable as we often hear a floated
around Gates continued with this brutal prosecution
of Pamela Carlyn. Take a listen
now you you, have you ever been on a podcast
called versus Trump? I think I was on a live
panel that the people who ran the podcast
called versus Trump on that. Do you remember
saying the following liberals tend to cluster
more conservatives, especially very conservative
people tend to spread out more perhaps because
they don't even want to be around themselves.
Did you say that? Yes, I did. Do. Do you understand
how that reflects contempt on people who are
conservative? No. What I was talking about
there was the natural tendency. If you put
the quote in context, the natural tendency
of a compactness requirement to favor a party
whose voters are more spread out too fast.
Hold on. Again, I'm very, I'm very limited
on time professor, and so I just have to say
when you talk about how liberals want to be
around each other and cluster and conservatives
don't want to be around each other and so
they have to spread out. It makes people,
you may not see this from, you know like the
ivory towers of your law school, but it makes
actual people in this country when you're
like, men don't get to interrupt me on this
time. Now, let me also suggest that when you
invoke the president's sons name here, when
you try to make a little joke out of referencing
Baron Trump, that does not lend credibility
to your argument. It makes you look mean,
so
understand, this is all they have. If they
had more, they would use it. She was on a
podcast in talking about how the districting
requirements help Republicans, they are biased
towards conservative. These are, these are
the requirements that got us the gerrymandering
that we now have that so favors Republicans.
While she was talking about that on a podcast,
she throws in a sort of a joke, but it's,
it's not even really a joke because it actually
does go to why there is a structural advantage
for Republicans in districting. Conservatives
don't even want to be near each other. It
is true that conservatives have more rural
tendencies. In other words, there is a systemic
structural bias where the party, the movement
that is more interested in living rurally
rather than living in an urban or more, more
condensed fashion, compact fashion that is
going to help Republicans have more districts
even with lower, uh, population density.
Anyway, understand that this an attempted
attack on her credibility, but it does nothing
to a sale. Her legal knowledge, which she
was there to provide and did in an extremely
accurate and precise way. Then Gates brings
up Trump's son. This was so overblown, Carlin
said during the hearings in talking about
how Trump can't be allowed to just control
everything. It can't be just everything is
the way Trump wants. She said, Trump doesn't
get to make Barron a Baron, meaning she doesn't
get to make his son Baron Trump a Monarch.
Right? A Baron is a sort of, I think entry
level, a Monarch of some kind and Republicans
went crazy pretending that it was an attack
on a kid. It's a complete and total joke because
that's all that they had. Here's one other
moment where another Republican tried to get
them to reveal by a show of hands how they
voted in 2016 which is of course something
they don't have to answer. He is allowed to
ask. They don't have to answer. This is Republican
Tom McClintock trying that as a strategy to
attack the character of the witnesses.
Mr McClintock. Thank you, mr chairman. Can
I begin just with a show of hands? How many
on the panel actually voted for Donald Trump
in 2016 I don't think we're obligated to say
anything about how we can start out. Just
show of hands. I will not. I think you've
made your positions. Professor Karlan very
boot with a gentleman who was suspended will
suspend the clock to I ever made to see me.
You may ask that question. Let me rephrase
that question. How many of you would clock
the staff for the moment? The gentleman may
ask the question, the witnesses don't have
to respond. How many of you started Donald
Trump in 2016 show of hands, not I keep not
raising our hands is not an indication of
an answer, sir. This
is all they had. Tell us how you voted. Did
you once make a joke on a podcast years ago?
Still I maintain, nothing may come of this,
but the lines of questioning from Republicans
made it so clear that they know they have
nothing because this is what they had to resort
to. Unfortunately. Also, that probably played
really well. I didn't watch any of the Fox
news stuff yesterday, but it wouldn't be surprising
to me if they had video of Matt Gates talking
about a podcast that professor Karlan appeared
on and framing it as, wow. Wow. What a brutal
indictment. It wouldn't shock me, but big
picture. We know that this type of stuff works
even though it is completely not based in
assessing the most important thing here, which
is the legal case for the impeach ability
of Donald Trump as if the entire worldwide
embarrassment that is the Trump Ukraine fiasco
could get any more embarrassing.